vanderpump rules' star james kennedy  denied from boarding a flight for being  it too drunk a source confirms to ET the  incident went down monday after the 24  year old reality star hosted a memorial  day bash at the Hard Rock Hotel and  Casino in Las Vegas with his pomp rules  co-star Lala Kent after the event at  James attempted to board a Southwest  flight back home to LA the only problem  he was a bit too intoxicated our source  revealed quote right before they closed  the doors the airline worker said James  couldn't get on because he was too drunk  the source also added at James and Lala  were yelling at each other in the  terminal explaining quote it looked like  a classic drunken fight between friends  we're told James was also joined by his  girlfriend miss sonoma county USA Raquel  abyss who stayed back with him as la la  got on the plane and left 80 has reached  out to James and his rep for coming